- [Narrator] This is Charles,
a San Esteban Island chuckwalla.
(lively, bouncy music)
Part of the iguana family,
chuckwallas are the largest
of the five species.
They are endangered due to
hunting and feral animals
preying on their eggs.
Charles is native to San Esteban Island,
a small island in the Gulf
of California, Mexico.
It is only in this region
where the San Esteban
Chuckwallas can be found.
Their coloration provides critical
camouflage from predators.
They don't drink water, instead,
getting all the water they
need from the plants they eat.
San Esteban chuckwallas can
reach over 2.5 feet in size.
They are very well adapted for desert life
and enjoy basking in
the sun in temperatures
consistently in the low hundreds.
This is the San Esteban chuckwalla.
(chiming beat)